The only overarching purpose or
direction that I can think of for
mankind as a whole is very well
expressed in the definition of humanity,
uh,
that Pierre Teilhard de Short on
provided.
Now he was a Jesuit priest who,
uh,
lived in China for a long time and was a
kind of an anthropologist.
His,
his definition of humanity was evolution
become conscious of itself and it's a
very powerful point of view if you think
about it.
My sense of humanity as a whole is
that's what it is.
We are alive,
become conscious,
uh,
and therefore become able to understand
what we're doing to set goals and they
all.
And that I think is possibly unique in
the universe.